[Music]
sometimes being pretty matters when
you're a video game and Max the curse of
Brotherhood demonstrates that point
perfectly hi everybody its senior editor
Kevin Van Ord standing in for reviewer
Jason Venter to tell you about max the
basic running and jumping sequences are
supplemented by interesting puzzles and
an unsurprising slew of collectibles but
none of it ever comes together in a way
that makes a truly favorable impression
until you stop to admire the gorgeous
visuals somehow everything that's good
and everything that's disappointing
about the game starts to feel a little
bit better you are max an irritable boy
who comes home to his annoying younger
brother Felix next by the lads
rambunctious obnoxious behavior
you read aloud the words of a spell
designed to make such nuisances
disappear I wish your traces could be
gone from all places those words take
almost immediate effect your sibling
disappears to avoid and you jump in
after him as regret over your
irresponsible actions takes old just
like that you've embarked on a journey
across a treacherous wilderness your
destination is the wizard moustachios
castle and your only weapon is a magic
marker that allows you to manipulate
your environment
max himself can crawl run walk jump and
drag things but that's the extent of his
moves he'd never get far without his
precious writing utensil which you must
use liberally pressing and holding the
right trigger suspends direct control of
Max and brings up a holographic image of
the tool which interacts with colorful
pieces of the architecture at your
direction for instance a dark green node
can extend a formal edge which you can
then use as a foothold an orange node
betrays the presence of a stone column
each interactive piece of nature has
variable limits signified by a steadily
draining supply of ink
you must figure out how to make the most
out of each resource as the game
progresses the marker gains additional
abilities and the solutions to puzzles
gradually require multiple steps in
later scenes sometimes feels like you're
playing a scribble simulator rather than
a platformer levels typically consist of
a series of open spaces where and you
must chain together a few environmental
effects and then hop along a few more
ledges or run along an unremarkable
corridor to reach the next such
challenge the difficulty lies in
figuring out what you're supposed to
accomplish in those more interactive
areas it's a pleasure to descend the
longest series of ledges protruding from
the face of a roaring waterfall admiring
the lush foliage and figuring out how to
reach the far side of each Ezard
checkpoint placement is typically
generous so that even a fall to your
doom means short-lived frustration at
the worst however you'll come across
numerous other situations that prove
frustrating because they require quicker
reflexes and more precise movement than
the game's controls readily facilitating
the worst such moments are chase
sequences which usually find max fleeing
from a giant troll or sliding along a
series of crumbling ruins if Max
suddenly needs you to produce a Ledge
lest he tumble into an abyss the marker
often materializes in a location that's
less than ideal for the task at hand
the moments when you're forced to play
through a particular scene several times
because you didn't anticipate a surprise
shift in the landscape are always
unwelcome even when you know exactly
what to do you may come across instances
where you'll have to make several
attempts before max jumps quite far
enough then grabs a vine that only just
barely has a chance of reaching him
there's some creativity on display for
the campaigns full five to seven hours
but mostly you'll perform the same few
road activities with only slight
variations aside from the aggravating
chase scenes a scavenger hunt for
collectables is the only detour max the
curse of Brotherhood is enormous ly
attractive and the puzzles are initially
quite satisfying before wearing out
their welcome you should consider taking
the plunge if you're looking for another
pretty platformer otherwise you're
probably better off waiting for a
different curse to come along
you
[Music]